I can't help but take this opportunity
to take at least one question so please
yeah ah wait hold on decorum right that
was the word we were using the corn uh
yes sir familiar face hi that's right
fake journalists
yes uh Trent nice to see you how do you
feel about Kansas City being one of the
named hosting cities for the uh 2026
World Cup here I was hoping for a
softball okay um
you know what I'm very excited truth
truth be told yeah Kansas City's gonna
be one of these teams uh I mean I love
this town what I am genuinely worried
about is once we get all these folks
from all over the world to come to
Kansas City and see our city eat our
food meet our people you're gonna have
you know a lot of folks that won't want
to move away that's what I'm worried
about
while many folks here in U.S are focused
on March Madness or the World Baseball
Classic Go Team USA tomorrow night by
the way we at the White House today are
going to focus on another sport which is
soccer
or football is some of my guests might
say
[Laughter]
specifically AFC Richmond and I can
neither confirm nor deny the existence
of the believe banners that we're seeing
around it you all may be seeing around
the White House complex today
it is an honor it is truly an honor to
have Coach lasso here with us today
on a serious note though because this is
actually very serious for the reasons
that they all hear uh Jason and his
castmates and there's a real message
around Mental Health
and they are meeting with the president
and the first lady as you all know this
afternoon on this important topic and as
you know the president has made mental
health the centerpiece of his Unity
agenda and I know that Jason wants to
share a few words and so coach lasso
Podium is yours I appreciate it thank
you thank you
um yeah I I truly did not know it was
going to be this one when uh
on the way here uh not until we're out
here uh and and uh so uh thank you for
taking an interest and I know you're
here for bigger reasons than us but I
just want to say that on behalf of
myself uh everyone here with me today
and the numerous other folks that that
uh it takes to make our show Ted lasso
it is sincerely an honor to visit the
White House and to have the opportunity
to speak to the president and to the
first lady about the importance of
mental health
um
so like no matter who you are no matter
where you live no matter who you voted
for we all probably I assume we all know
someone who has uh or I've been that
someone ourselves actually that's
struggled that's felt isolated that's
felt anxious that has felt alone right
and it's actually one of the many things
that uh Believe It or Not uh that we all
have in common as human beings right and
so um
that means that we it's something that
we can all you know and should talk
about with one another when we're
feeling that way or when when we
recognize that in someone feeling that
way uh so please you know we encourage
everyone and there's a big theme of the
show is like to check in with your you
know your neighbor your co-worker your
friends your family uh and ask how
they're doing and and listen sincerely
you know I mean you all ask questions
for a living but you also listen for a
living so you know who am I preaching to
the choir that is okay um and look and
while look while it's easier said than
done I I we also have to know that we
shouldn't be afraid to ask for help
ourselves and that does take a lot
especially when it's something that has
such a
negative stigma to it such as mental
health and it doesn't need to be that
way and if you can ask for that help
from a professional fantastic if it
needs to be a loved one equally as good
in a lot of ways because it's sometimes
you just need to let that pressure that
that pressure valve release uh the
president is working on and his in his
own team although his team is real our
team has make-believe I don't think I
don't know that despite what the people
at FIFA and EA will tell you we are
actually a make-believe team but uh you
know they're working very hard to make
sure that the that you know that option
is available to us as many Americans as
possible uh now look I know in this town
uh a lot of folks don't always agree
right uh and don't always feel heard
seen listened to yes but I truly believe
that we should all do our best to help
take care of each other that's that's my
own personal belief I think that's
something that everybody up here on
stage believes in this that's things we
talked about in The Writer's room we
talk about in the editing room and
everything in between uh and just like
you know you just want to emulate you
know these make-believe folks that we
all play at AFC Richmond and and the way
they take care of one another that is
the wish fulfillment of the show aside
for me playing coach and these guys
being professional footballers you know
that's like you know that's that's
that's a big part of the show
foreign